so how did you go from having 10 pounds
to getting a deal like what was the deal
what were the figures how did that
happen that's
great and i know since then you've gone
on to get a lot more deals
but how did you get that first deal what
happened so yes first deal
i watched few of your uh rent to hmm
videos as well and winners on wednesday
the guys who did
hatchimal yeah and i watched that video
again and again to find out what exactly
how i can
get my first property and then i kept on
viewing
and when i started using the script i
get no no no from most of the agent no
then i found i think i'm doing some kind
of mistake over here
then i watched the video again and i
found the script that you are
using and i use that script and i
got my property but i had no money for
to put the rent first month rent and
deposit
so i applied for the loan then i took
the loan money and i put it in my first
property
how much was the loan so the loan was 9
000 pounds
okay big risk right exactly and and some
people would say
don't do it you know you've got no money
you're you're you've just got back from
afghanistan from the army
you know you've been watching samuel's
videos you've been to some of his
courses
don't go and get a loan that's risky and
they tell you not to do it
exactly did anyone say that to you did
you what were your friends and your
family and your associates and your
what were they all saying when you were
doing this did they think it was great
or were they concerned oh definitely not
no so
like they used to tell me no don't do it
it's a risky
you might lose your money how are you
going to pay the loan back don't don't
step in
just do whatever you are doing it's fine
we like the way you
are so this kind of stuff there yeah try
and protect you yeah trying to correct
me yeah that's always what happens
yeah exactly yeah yeah so but anyway so
from my inside uh i really wanted to do
this uh property journey i want to
i really wanted to study this but yes
and i took my step
and i took the loan then i started my
journey in property how are you juggling
your time in all of this because you
live
in wales yeah the properties are in
london you've got four
you're going for a fifth you told me you
want 10 by march next year yes that's
correct
how are you managing your time how is
this happening so yeah that was
a good question so yeah every weekend me
and my wife we used to drive from wells
to
london for the property and
after that i hired one manager and after
that another guy came in
so right now i have my team including me
we are three people
one guy is doing maintenance and
viewings other guys
checking the documents referencing
tenants and i'm the one
looking for new deals at the moment okay
and are they let's go sorry
sorry you've got three people now in
your team you've employed two people
yeah and you're paying them out of the
profits
at the moment so it's been only a month
so they said they don't want
income they want what they are looking
for the outcome they want to learn about
the property
so they are not after the you're a smart
guy nick
thank you very much so so you basically
put them on work experience
uh so actually they were my tenants what
yes that's correct okay and they said
they want to work with me
yeah ask them why you want to work with
it because they said i'm looking to
learn from
looking about to learn to learn about
the properties from you
and i said okay i'm happy to have you in
my team but you need to have the same
working spirit that i have and we had
few uh interviews as well
yeah and these guys they were incredible
so they just instantly want to join my
team
and they're working hard so yeah they're
working hard so one guy is busy doing
viewings other guys
looking after new qualifying their
property in the market and i'm the one
doing viewings
and dealing with agents wow
i mean geez i've got to say i'm
incredibly impressed thank you very much
you've done ridiculously well talked
how how how did you do all this give me
the secrets